bonsoir monsieur beaulac d'abord cette
décision de la cour suprême à s'applique
immédiatement et partout oui application
pancanadienne parce que soyons clair
elle a été prise en vertu à la fois de
la charte canadienne et de la charte
québécoise
évidemment ça concerne un dossier au
saguenay au premier chef mais la
jurisprudence en de cette décision sera
d'application pancanadienne et sa touche
toutes les religions - seulement les la
religion catholique soit c'est une autre
précision importante c'est évidemment
dans le dossier une pratique associée à
la religion catholique mais la décision
aura un impact sur toute pratique de
conseil municipal ou d'un organisme
public qu'on peut associer à un conseil
municipal
peu importe la religion alors on peut
penser à des villes à prédominance jouit
par exemple comment instead à homestead
sur l'île de montréal qui ne pourraient
ainsi s'associer dans leur pratique dans
l'exercice de leurs fonctions à une
religion la religion juive dans mon
exemple dont la cour suprême a décidé de
ne pas se prononcer sur les symboles
religieux on pense bien sûr aux crucifix
à l'assemblée nationale
mais est ce que cette décision ne
pourrait pas quand même avoir une portée
plus large
oui c'est intéressant de souligner parce
que l
dit explicitement ne pas vouloir se
prononcer sur cet aspect de symboles
religieux or dans plusieurs de ces
commentaires le juge gascon semble un
souhaitez envoyer un message que le test
ni plus ni moins en matière de liberté
de religion et de neutralité de l'état
va justement s'intéresser sur les
réalités associés à leur religion
or d'assigner de faire penser certaines
pratiques essentiellement associé à la
religion comme étant des symboles
culturels patrimoniaux historique ne
semblerait pas pouvoir passer le test el
khettabi dans la décision de ce qu'on
fait en fait c'est l'argument qu'on
donne quand on parle du christiane
entend régulièrement et c'est un peu un
signe avant coureur que là qu'on ne
serait pas prête à recevoir ou accepter
un tel argumentaire très rapidement les
signes religieux dans la fonction
publique est ce que la sk une porte et
là dessus oui ben c'est un autre et les
matins de non dits dans la décision
d'aujourd'hui parce que évidemment on se
concentre sur les institutions ne
l'étant pas de neutralité
c'est dans l'exercice de leur fonction
publique qu'un représentant de l'état ne
peut pas s'afficher s'associer à une
religion or à quelques reprises le juge
gascon prend bien soin justement de
distinguer cette situation à l'exercice
d'un droit personnel de la liberté de
religion donc un signe ostentatoire
autrement dit il ne tomberait pas sous
le coup de la décision d'aujourd'hui
parce que ce n'est pas une institution
de l'état mais bien un individu qui
travaille pour l'état c'est très clair
on va